well let's get the very latest now from
Cinema who joins us from Istanbul from
where she's monitoring developments and
seen him 24 hours on the the extent of
the devastation is all too apparent
isn't it and the focus of course very
much on the rescue effort
exactly exactly as 24 the the first
seven to two hours are very important
Nick and we left behind 24 hours and
still there are areas that the rescue
teams haven't been able to reach some of
them are in the rurals of those 10
cities that have been affected by the
earthquake but cities like hatai and
takiatric is southern city border with
Syria and other one of the cities that
was strongly hit by yesterday's
earthquake are in trouble because the
the highways are broken there cracked
rescue workers weren't able to reach out
properly to those places but there are
four airports that had that have been
shut down since yesterday for civil
aviation that's making things hard
making rescue efforts to reach to the
area late and rescue teams and the
government is losing time this means
civilians are losing time and the season
is very important here as also you said
there are cold temperatures people are
out living outside according to the
official information more than 3030 uh
330 000 people spend the night in
shelters in a university buildings or
dormitory buildings so people who have
cars who had some opportunity were able
to leave these cities at this and to
outskirts to have a safe place but there
are hundreds of thousands of people
trapped in the cities some of them under
the rubbles and as it snow snows as it
rains in some of the places I have been
listening to the weather news since the
morning in some places it is minus four
minus one a zero temperature and since
this area is far from the sea the the
climate is dry so it is much it they
feel much colder other than usual and
people were people just took to the
streets as they were shaken some of them
do not have even blankets and we are
seeing on social media that a baby
froze to that so uh these are critical
times for those civilians who are
waiting to be rescued and also critical
times for the rescue workers because we
are hearing that even themselves the
rescue workers are having trouble while
they're working because uh some of the
buildings that are that have leveled
down when the rescue workers get on them
when there is an Aftershock which is
still ongoing there there have been more
than 250 aftershocks since yesterday's
Quake rescue workers also need to leave
these buildings so this is all about the
challenge tough times for turkey and a
very difficult times for the civilians
who are waiting for help
there are at least 16 000 person eight
Personnel who are in the region right
now and as per Istanbul government owner
stated this morning as of 6 a.m Istanbul
local time seven to one airplanes took
off from Istanbul Airport
thousands of uh eight personnel and
eight volunteers who are about to reach
to the region to help others but will
not be will not be enough probably Nick
all right back with you as the day
unfolds thanks very much indeed for that
update soon because earlier they're
monitoring the situation from Istanbul